we just got some major bombshell leaks
for the iphone 14 pro which include both
good and bad news but i think the good
news is so good that the bad news isn't
even gonna matter at this point so
without further ado i'm gonna get into
the bad news about the iphone 14 pro
first and then i'll get into the crazy
leaks about the new camera system and
why it's gonna be the biggest camera
update we've ever had you've probably
been seeing these leaked renders
floating around the internet over the
past week or so showing off a new iphone
design that features the dual hole punch
camera cut out on the front display
which i think is extremely exciting and
i personally think it's going to look
amazing in person but when you go over
to the back side the camera bump looks
almost identical to the one we already
have on the iphone 13 pro so when i
first saw these renders i thought they
were fake but we just got some
confirmation from the most important
source in regards to the iphone 14
design yes that's john prosser because
back in september right before the
iphone 13 design reveal he decided to
leak the iphone 14 design which he said
would have a completely flush glass back
as well as a single hole punch camera on
the front and obviously that was very
exciting because that design would be
completely unique since it would get rid
of the squares camera bump on the back
that we currently have but to be honest
right from the start i had my doubts
about this design and the reason for
that is because we've had some very
specific camera leaks from ming chi quo
claiming that the iphone 14 pro would
come with a 48 megapixel camera capable
of shooting 8k video so to me it seemed
absolutely impossible for apple to
somehow pull off completely flush
cameras on the back of the new iphone
design so because of that i worked with
renders by shylesh to create some iphone
14 pro renders based on john prosser's
renders created by ian zelbo but with my
own predictions added to it and the main
difference i added was having the flush
glass back but actually protruding the
three main camera bumps further out from
the frame because to me there's no way
they could have flush camera design if
they're upgrading to a new 48 megapixel
camera so it's gonna have to stick out
and with that said guess what just
happened the other day john prosser
himself made a new video admitting that
his flush iphone 14 pro design might
actually be for the iphone 15 instead so
it's very likely that his leaks were
just very early and he even said that
these recent leaked renders are probably
the actual new iphone 14 pro design so
basically we now have various sources
agreeing that the rear squarish camera
bump design will likely be sticking
around for another year and that right
there is the bad news because we've all
been hyped up for a complete iphone
redesign but it looks like we're only
getting a partial redesign this time
with the removal of the notch on the
display but don't worry because like i
said in the intro i believe that the
good news that was just leaked far
outweighs the bad news so let's get
right into it way back in april of 2021
almost a full year ago ming chu ko
reported that the new high-end 2022
iphone 14 pro models would come with a
48 megapixel camera that is capable of
shooting 8k video and making it even
better he said that the new camera would
be capable of supporting both 48
megapixel output while simultaneously 48
megapixel output while simultaneously
outputting 12 megapixel photos by
utilizing pixel binning to essentially
merge four nearby pixels into one larger
pixel which significantly increases the
pixel size up to about 2.5 microns which
is larger than any android phone out
there so makes you close predictions
back in april of last year were that
this new 48 megapixel sensor would
elevate mobile phone camera photography
to a new level and i completely agree
but now almost a full year later we've
gotten multiple reports that back up
what ming has been saying all along
including a report from trend force
claiming that the 48 megapixel camera is
coming to the iphone 14 pro models and
just the other day ming chakra tweeted
in agreement about the new leaked iphone
14 pro schematics claiming that the new
larger and more prominent rear camera of
the 14 pro models is due to apple
upgrading the wide camera to 48
megapixels and then to put the cherry on
top we just got a bombshell leak from a
weibo account detailing the actual specs
and features of the iphone 14 pro's new
48 megapixel camera and as you can see
there are a bunch of confusing bits of
info with no explanation but luckily we
here at maxtec used to actually review
cameras and compare them and we used to
shoot weddings full time so we know a
thing or two about cameras so let's go
ahead and dig into each little detail
starting with the one slash 1.3 inches
which is actually the sensor size which
is going to be similar to the one to the
s22 ultra around
69.12 millimeters squared and if you
want to compare that to the current
iphone 13 pro max's main camera sensor
it's actually going to be 57
larger than the current one which is a
huge difference
now moving on to the next detail we have
1.22 um dpaf
and dpaf means dual pixel autofocus
which is currently the standard now 1.22
um stands for 1.22 microns which is a
measure of the size of each individual
pixel and on the surface it looks like a
downgrade compared to the pixel size of
the current iphone 13 pro which is
sitting at 1.9 microns but before you
think this is really bad news the reason
for the smaller pixel size is because
there are now four times as many pixels
inside of the sensor since we're going
from a 12 megapixel sensor to a 48
megapixel so the pixels themselves have
to get smaller and the pixel size
directly impacts how much light enters
into each pixel so a smaller 1.22 micron
pixel size means less light entering the
pixel which means worse low light
performance because apple's gonna have
to raise the iso or the artificial
exposure to properly adjust the
brightness for a dim or low light
scenario but wait a minute since apple
is gonna be utilizing pixel bidding to
merge four pixels together into one thus
outputting a 12 megapixel photo from
that 48 megapixel sensor the effective
pixel size actually gets doubled from
1.22 microns up to
2.44 microns which is almost exactly
what ming chico reported last year in
april and this new 2.44 micron pixel
size is gonna be a huge deal because
it's actually gonna let
28.4 percent more light come into the
sensor compared to the iphone 13 pro
sensor with 1.9 micron pixels which is
going to be a very big deal for low
light photography and videography but
the main problem with all of this is
that larger sensors like the 57 larger
one going into the iphone 14 pro
actually require longer and larger glass
elements that protrude even more in
order to maintain the same aperture so
if apple were to maintain the same f 1.5
aperture on this new much larger sensor
the camera bump would have to stick out
quite a bit more than it already is and
the crazy thing that backs that up is
that main chaquelle came out with a
report saying that the diagonal length
of the 48 megapixel camera will increase
by 25 to 35
while the height of the seven layer lens
will increase by five to ten percent
which is why the new leaked renders are
showing a much larger camera bump that
protrudes even more than the current
iphone 13 pro now with that out of the
way let's move on to the next detail in
the list dual 11
12 bit ad which relates to the sensor
shooting 11 or 12 bit colors and then
converting it down to 8 or 10 bit that
apple uses and right below that the
pixel level bonding and dram on the chip
will be used for hardware level pixel
binning of taking the 48 megapixel
sensor and converting it into a 12
megapixel photo or video recording and i
do want to mention that when it's very
bright outside the camera will likely
automatically use the full 48 megapixel
sensor for maximum detail but when it
starts to get dim or even in dark low
light the camera will automatically
switch to binning down to 12 megapixels
to take advantage of the larger 2.44
micron pixel size when bini now moving
on to the next detail we have clear hdr
which i believe stands for apple's
extended dynamic range video recording
which combines two different exposures
to get better hdr results and then dol
hdr stands for dolby vision hdr and the
dol clear hdr stands for dolby vision
recording while also using the extended
dynamic range now below that i honestly
don't know what these two things mean so
i won't even try but moving further we
have various recording formats using the
full resolution sensor but that does not
matter because apple always shoots video
in 16x9 format which is actually at the
bottom of the list the first 16x9 12-bit
120fps option means that the sensor is
actually capable of recording 8k
resolution at 120fps which i don't think
apple will even allow and below that we
have clear hdr at 60 fps so that's 8k
60fps with extended dynamic range
enabled which is gonna be the absolute
game changer and then finally dolby
vision extended dynamic range with
11-bit colors at 24 fps which will be
the flagship 8k format so basically with
all of that said and explained the point
that i'm trying to make is that the
iphone 14 pro models will get a massive
step up in terms of camera quality
destroying the other android phones that
currently already shoot 8k video but
they're limited to only 24 fps and the
quality is sometimes even worse than the
iphone's current 4k video quality so if
you're thinking about buying an iphone
13 pro right now i would honestly hold
off until the iphone 14 pro models are
revealed because i think this will be by
far the biggest camera update we've ever
seen on the iphone and with that said
hopefully you enjoyed this video and if
you did go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and definitely check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]